ça va d'un pas en avant sa photo fait
passer une formalité c'est juste pour
prendre la température à moins d'une
catastrophe due par omission j'espère
que tu as commencé à faire ses bagages
tu peux aller faire un café en attendant
qui t'appelle dans la cuisine
ça entre autres et c'est très bien ça
serait sous bonne humeur par contre les
gars qui l'on doit tous installés mont
fuji à manger une urgence compte a de la
chance
moi c'est pas bon tout de suite mal aux
tripes ans que je suis pas prête
bonjour ça va
comme vous savez votre nomination en
tant qu'expert en biochimie en afrique
de l'ouest a été approuvée dont vous
partez très bientôt
marie-jeanne aux abris faits mais on
voudrait vous entendre maintenant mais
marie jeanne est très satisfait de votre
préparation tous les tests cognitifs
sont très bons et vous avez aussi réussi
les tests de mise en situation et vous
de votre côté quand vous sentez en riz
excusez moi on a besoin de quelqu'un
pour placer un mouchard sur un
ordinateur il faut y aller maintenant
elle pas un test je les y reprendra plus
tabler sur mieux
les patrons de marina oubliée sonore des
moteurs à l'hôtel c'est une chance
inespérée pour placer un mouchard vous
ouvre la batterie ou le col est tout
simplement l'intérieur donnait ça c'est
une clé qui donne accès à toutes les
chambres de l'hôtel vous avez la chambre
30,63 donc là c'est le mouchard vous
partez faites attention et utiliser les
sas
[Musique]
sa robe
king soyez vigilants
l'impression d'être suivi ressortez du
ca s'est immédiatement sinon descendez
au niveau -1
deux vigiles vous attendront le muet et
inuits 8
véhicule
ensuite pour aller à l'hôtel prenez le
bus ou le métro
les métros illusions se perdre dans la
foule
rivière ne vous êtes pas suivi une
voiture est stationnée bizarrement
quelques arrêts multitude étrange vous
voyez une personne que vous avez déjà
croisé au moindre doute interrompu la
mission
[Musique]
quand vous arrivera à l'autel
il faut être très discret si on vous
appelle ne vous retournez pas personne
n'est censé savoir que vous êtes là
touristes hommes et femmes d'affaires
réceptionniste concierge ou femme de
ménage il faut vous méfier de tout le
monde
le patron de marina sera peut-être
encore dans le lobby il peut décider de
remonter dans sachant pas un problème ça
leur fait attention et ne perdez pas de
temps et il est décidé
ne vous arrêtez pas ne demander aucun
renseignement excusez moi que vous
parlez en à fond
ne prenez pas l'ascenseur avec d'autres
personnes la chambre est au troisième
le badge qu'on vous a confié ouvrir à la
chambre une fois à l'intérieur soyez
silencieux lâchant peut-être sur écoute
repérer tout de suite l'ordinateur pour
poser le mouchard ça nous permettra de
géolocaliser le patron de marina en
permanence personne ne doit vous
surprendre et personne ne doit vous voir
ni entrer ni sortir
[Musique]
pour repartir ne prenez pas l'ascenseur
passer par les couloirs mais attention
repérez vous voir c'est un vrai
labyrinthe chercher les issues de
secours les plus proches et prenez les
escaliers
[Musique]
venir au bureau emprunter un autre ça
c'est prenez un autre véhicule qu'elle
allait bonne chance
bravo votre mission commence le 9 mai on
compte sur vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]